MENGRAN HE: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Google Cloud OnAir
live webinar from Google Cloud.
And we are hosting webinar
sessions every Tuesday.
My name is Mengran He, and
this is my colleague, Harish.
Today, we'll be talking about
how Credit Karma improved
the working efficiency at scale
by using the Google BigQuery
and a Looker dashboard.
You can ask a question at
any time on the platform.
And we have Googlers
standing by to answer them.
Let's get started.
I'm a marketing analyst
at Credit Karma.
And this is Harish Gaggar.
HARISH GAGGAR: Hi.
This is Harish Gaggar.
I'm a staff BI analyst
at Credit Karma.
MENGRAN HE: Let me introduce
Credit Karma for a minute.
So Credit Karma is a
financial technology company
founded in 2007, best
known for providing
credit scores for free for
our 80 million members.
And we can always provide
the data-driven insights
and identify the
opportunities for our members
and make the most
of their money.
Whether someone is interested
in getting a better
deal on their loan, like
a credit card or mortgage,
or simply just need to monitor
their identity or credit
information, we can always
provide the actionable tools
for them and help them make
their financial progress.
Some quick stats
about Credit Karma--
as I just mentioned, we have
more than 80 million members
in the US and Canada.
With that being said, if
Credit Karma was a country,
it would be the 16th largest
country in the world, which
is ahead of Germany.
And there's around
$40 billion of credit
originated through Credit
Karma over the last 10 years.
That's bigger than the GDP of
Kenya, Jordan, and Iceland.
And there are around
20 million Americans
who have applied for a product
like credit card offers
on Credit Karma platform.
That's more people than
were born in the US
over the last five years.
And there's around half of the
US Millennials use Credit Karma
app.
That's more than the
number of Millennials
who watch Hulu or Amazon Prime.
As I mentioned, Credit Karma is
a highly data-driven company.
We can always provide
the actionable tools
and help our members to make
their financial progress.
So Harish, would
you please introduce
what data infrastructure looked
like in the past and nowadays
at Credit Karma?
HARISH GAGGAR: Absolutely.
Thanks, Mengran.
So before 2016, we had
in-house columnar database.
And our team was
spending a lot of time
in terms of scalability
and performance tuning--
scalability in
terms of, they kept
changing the dashboard
database configurations
to support our database needs.
And they were also
spending a lot
of time in hardware maintenance
and also the expensive license
renewal.
And on the performance
tuning side,
the query's performance
was really slow
because most of them are
coming from the complex
join on the columnar database.
And it's delaying, overall,
our ETL processing time.
And analyst team were
waiting for a long time
to see the up-to-date data.
So we ran with a lot of the POC.
And finally, we
found that BigQuery
was the best database for us
to support our business needs.
So let me cover what our
data stack looks like now.
So from 2016, Credit Karma data
stack growth from 30 terabytes
to the 1.8 petabytes.
And we collect nine
terabytes of data every day.
And we run many model
predictions, also.
So this is all about volume.
But also, we build
many API jobs which
are able to connect the
various different sources.
For example, we are connecting
Salesforce for finance data,
and we're connecting
Facebook for media,
and Google AdWords
for marketing ads.
And like that, there
are other API jobs, too,
which we run on every day,
and land it with a BigQuery
and do our Looker
reporting on that.
On the other side of the other
type of jobs, which is mostly
the machine learning
models, that,
we're also running
on the BigQuery.
So for example, if you want to
forecast our daily active users
and if you want to forecast
how many emails we want to send
and what kind of
offer we want to send,
and if you want to predict
our scoring rates--
so all these different
models, also, we are running.
So I would like to thank Google
and their entire support team,
who really helped us to
brought to this position.
And it does also help us in
our day-to-day business value.
Now, we have three
different use cases,
which is talk more about
how we leverage a BigQuery
on our day-to-day life.
So first use case is daily
active user forecast.
I will let Mengran
to try this one.
MENGRAN HE: Thanks, Harish.
So let me define daily
active user for a second.
So daily active user
is a metric to measure
the number of members who
come to our site every day.
And it can be reflected
by the way we connect
with our members,
and also measured
by the product performance.
So a better daily active
user forecast model
would allow our stakeholders to
monitor the product performance
in a very prompt way.
And we use Google
BigQuery database
to store the model inputs
and also the forecast result,
and then migrate the result
from the BigQuery database
to Looker dashboard so
that our stakeholders can
monitor the performance
and then compare
against the actual daily active
user on the dashboard directly.
So in this way, they can
improve the speed and quality
of their business decision for
engaging with our active users.
Prior to the current,
improved data infrastructure
and the pipeline,
we had to train
the model manually every time
we launched a new initiative.
So it cost a long
turn-around time
for adjusting those impact
of the new initiatives.
And also, we had to collect data
from different channel owners
or organizations, which
means it's hard for us
to unify the model input and
then produce the output very
promptly for our stakeholders.
Because the data
collection is siloed,
it adds up the layer of channel
dependency onto the pipeline.
And also, human error might be
involved during the process.
So Harish, would
you please tell us
how business intelligence
team at Credit Karma
solved those challenges and
improved the infrastructure?
HARISH GAGGAR: Absolutely.
We have an automated
data pipeline system
which connects our
expected email click
ratios and the actual
email click ratios.
And then we forecast
how actual users
are going to perform on
the email what we send.
On this data pipeline,
we use Airflow,
which is an open-source
tool from Airbnb.
This is for managing
the complex workflows
and scheduling the jobs.
First thing is, I would
like to cover how we
drive the expected email click.
So in this, our
pipeline is first
reading the Google spreadsheet.
The Google spreadsheet, we
are running through Python.
And the Excel sheet
is mostly maintained
by our campaign managers,
where, day-to-day basis,
they are continuously updating
our expected email and push
notification click volume.
Once the Python program
learns [INAUDIBLE],,
it loads the data
back to the BigQuery.
And then on the other side, we
connect back the BigQuery again
for our actual data.
So once we have
our expected email
and push notification
data and the actual email
and push notification data,
we combine both this data
and prepare our data
set for the model.
Then, we send this data back
to our machine learning model.
And that machine
learning model trying
to predict the daily users--
how they're going
to take an email,
how they're going to
read those emails,
perform over those emails.
And then we send this forecast
number back to the BigQuery.
And ultimately, then, we connect
this Looker to the BigQuery
to see the overall performance
on our daily forecast.
MENGRAN HE: Thanks, Harish.
So because of those improvements
on the data pipeline,
we got the chance to improve the
flexibility and the robustness
of our forecast model, just like
the daily active user forecast.
And also, our stakeholders can
get a better and up-to-date
report directly on
the Looker dashboard
for their business planning.
And they also can
monitor the product
and the channel performance on
the Looker dashboard directly.
And it improved the
working efficiency a lot.
And next, Harish will talk
about how Credit Karma used
machine learning tools to
improve the email targeting
efficiency.
HARISH GAGGAR: Yes.
Thanks, Mengran.
So here, in this
particular use case,
we are trying to improve the
overall targeting efficiency
on the email notification.
Before I proceed on
the remaining slide,
let me talk more about
what model-driven email is.
Model-driven email is a
machine learning model
where, especially,
we are looking
for what kind of offer
users are searching--
for example, if they are
looking for a credit card
or personal loan
or a mortgage loan.
So based on the requirement,
we predict the users
who most likely tend
to get those e-mails,
and who also like
to open those emails
and click on those emails, and
then take the offer from us.
I will cover the data
pipeline more in detail.
But I want to first
explain what are
the challenges we had before.
So these are the
couple of points here.
We have a huge amount
of variables to support.
So we have 80
million-plus members.
And there are 1,000-plus
input variables.
It was very difficult
and it was very
time-consuming and
resource-intensive,
too, to collect all
this data collection,
and then send those data back
to the model, and then score,
and then send to the users.
It was almost a
nightmare for us to run
those huge amount of data
on the columnar database.
And there was no manual check--
I mean, there were no quality
checks, also, in place.
And we don't know
what are the data
anomaly we found over
those emails and variables.
Many variables are coming
with a blind values,
or they don't have any values.
So there was no point in
running a model on such values.
So it was very difficult
to identify such problems
without an automated
[INAUDIBLE] system.
I will talk more about how
we solved those challenges.
Again, we use
Airflow to implement
such end-to-end pipeline.
This pipeline helps
us to collect the data
over all the users who
perform on the emails
in the last few months.
And we collect all those
data, run the scoring,
and then, finally,
send out an email.
So let me start with a
little bit more detail
on how this pipeline works.
This pipeline actually
works on the three models.
One is the impression to click.
That means that when we send
out an email to our users
and they saw the email and
they click on that email,
that means impression to click.
And the second model is
click to applications--
when they try to click
on the offers and they
try to fill all
their information
on the partner's site and
then submit an application.
And the third
model is approval--
once they submit an
application, their application's
sent to our partners.
And then our partners
make a decision
whether they get approval
on their offers or not.
So in the first step,
in the Google BigQuery,
we try to collect all
this three model data.
So for impression to click
and click to application,
we collect those data
points from the user recent
[INAUDIBLE] history--
how they perform over the
email in the past few months.
And for the approval
model, we rely
on our online
recommendation system team,
where they given us more idea
about what are the approval
odds for our members.
So once we collect all
this three model data set,
we run the queries, and
then we store the data
into the Google Cloud Storage.
That is for preparing
the training data set.
Then, once the
data set is ready,
we send those data
back to the TensorFlow.
So TensorFlow is helping us on--
this is another cloud service
we get from Google where
we are able to run our
machine learning model on all
this three data set.
So this model is actually
scoring every member
on the thousands of
variables, just to make sure
that we make a right
ranking on every member,
that what offers they're
supposed to receive.
So the scoring is calculated
entirely through this model.
And again, store it
back to the BigQuery.
So once we have our
scoring set ready,
now we want to
drive the scoring,
and now we want to drive
our scoring data set
through the Excel sheet.
So this Excel sheet, it's
all about the campaign sheet.
Here, we maintain the
different email campaigns.
So our campaign
managers come in,
and they keep adding
the new campaigns,
and they're modifying
the existing campaigns.
And they change the
behavior of those campaigns.
That means, for
example, if I want
to send out an email
to the users who
have a score between 600 or 700
with an age range of 30 to 35--
so they change those criteria,
and they look for what offer
we need to send to those users.
So they select all those
criteria over the Excel sheet.
Our pipeline would automatically
read this Excel sheet
and combine this scoring
data set together.
And then we run our targeting
queries in the BigQuery.
So those targeting
queries are all
about figure it out, who
are eligible for sending out
a new email.
So once we have those
targeting queries ready.
Then we send this data
back to the Hermes.
Hermes is an internal
tool which allows
us to send out an
email to our members
with their specific offer needs.
MENGRAN HE: And,
Harish, would you
please introduce what
Hermes is at Credit Karma
and how we utilize Hermes to
send the email to our targeting
users?
HARISH GAGGAR: Great question.
So Hermes is an internal tool
for the user-level targeting
where we can allow marketing
analysts to write their own SQL
query and decide the
range of the users
to whom they want to send an
email and what kind of offer
they want to filter out.
MENGRAN HE: Thanks, Harish.
HARISH GAGGAR: Overall,
with this data pipeline,
it's helped a lot.
It's not just improved overall
efficiencies-- also improve--
it help us to send out the
right offer to the users.
This helps us in, over all,
our engagement on the emails.
And also, it reduced
the overall resources
to collect the data every
time and refresh the data,
run the model, and send out
up-to-date emails every time.
So this whole
automated system has
reduced a lot of the main
power and also improved
the overall data processing
time and also add a lot of value
to our business.
And we also have Looker pointing
to the email campaigns data
where we do the
measurement check--
how each campaign is performing.
For example, if you
send a Chase card
to the particular members,
how many members, basically,
open those emails?
How many of them click on that?
How many of them take
the offer from us?
So all this, we continuously
drive on the local dashboards.
And based on that, we're
going back and re-engineering
our entire data--
re-engineering our
model to make sure
that we have the
right data set and we
have right feature
set to ensure that we
keep delivering the best email
to our members as we can.
MENGRAN HE: This
is really helpful,
because email is one of our
most efficient way of targeting
our users, and also how
we engage with our users.
Sending a more relevant
message with the right amount
of frequency are pretty
critical to our business.
And next, Harish is going to
wrap up our last use case--
how we obtained a better
model for user acquisition
and a better offer pricing
on the search media.
HARISH GAGGAR: Absolutely.
So this is one of our
end of use case, where
we are trying to improve
the overall user engagement
and user experience
when they are
looking for any offer on the
page search and display media.
So how this work
is, we have a Google
written on [INAUDIBLE]
algorithm that
allow us to bid in auctions
at the user level granularity.
And this also help
us in overall quality
of the new user engagement
based on their monetizations.
So monetization's
all about how users
click on emails in the
past and how they took
the offers over the GoogleAds.
And ultimately, this
help us to send a--
it increases overall efficiency
in sending the overall revenue
to the [? CK ?] and
based on our target.
So there are, like before,
I explained more about how
this data pipeline works, how
we improve the automated ad
campaigns, the features.
Let me first explain what are
the challenges we had before,
why we got less traffic
in the past over our ads,
and how we get the flat
value on every transaction.
So we had this flat
to flat rate concept
initially on every credit
card application of our ads.
This flat to flat value also
means that what kind of users
come to Google and take the
offer from us in the past.
And This base, also,
is all about these user
sets are coming from
different user segments.
Like, for example, they are
coming with a different score
band and age band.
They are coming with a specific
platform, like mobile or web.
And then they are coming in
the last seven days or 10 days,
or any months, or not.
And it's also about
they are coming
from the organic or
display media or not.
So based on these
different media searches,
and based on the
overall mixed traffic,
we were defining the average
weight on the offers.
So this average rate scoring,
it was good for the campaign
analytics, but it was not good
for the user-level scoring.
So ultimately, we were getting
the flat rate for every credit
card transitions.
That actually slowed down
the overall revenue growth.
And we also had a difficulty
in identifying the issues
in the pipeline.
For example, when I talk
about, in the earlier point,
how the different user
segments come in on the site,
and they take the
offer from us--
there was the issue where data
is not normally distributed.
And we were not sure that what
kind of volumes are coming
and how the date is coming.
And ultimately, we are
spending a lot of money
on our ad campaigns.
So overall, it was impacting
our transition to revenue
on our credit card
applications on the ads.
So this is how we
solved the challenges.
We built the data pipeline,
which automatically collects
all the user history, how they
perform over the GoogleAds.
So this is like, for
example, if users are
coming with a specific segment.
So we make sure that we
collect all the data set
for a few months.
So what we did is, we've entered
in our database in a BigQuery.
And then we figure it out--
what the user behaviors are.
For example, it's not
all about five segments.
It's also about
thousands of variables
for that given member--
how he actually came to a
site, at which time he came in,
from where he came
in, and what kind of
offer he were looking for--
not just on our website.
It's also overall on the media.
And we collect all
these data points.
And then we store them in
the Google Cloud Storage.
And then we run our
machine learning model
to figure out the propensity
of buying the offer from us.
So once we have
this data set ready,
we send it back to the Google.
The Google AdWords has their
own algorithm [INAUDIBLE],,
which is written on
[? Adspin. ?] That algorithm
collects this data set.
And that's run their own
scoring on those data set.
And then it's determined
that, hey, this
is the users most
tends to likely take
this particular
offer from our ads.
And we ultimately send all
this data back to the BigQuery.
And then we have a
Looker again, which
is connecting to the
BigQuery, and see
the overall performance-- how
these things are happening,
what kind of users are coming
every day, what kind of offers
they are looking for, and
where we can improve more.
So ultimately, this
helps us a lot.
There was no manual work.
Our BigQuery's automatically
executing on a scheduled basis.
They collect all the data
points on the user behavior.
And it automatically is
sent to the Google AdWords.
Google AdWords decide their
own scoring and target.
So it's a good align with our
incentive between the BigQuery
and the Credit Karma data.
And I would say that it
also helps us in a way
that it's use our
proprietary data,
and it makes our media
channel more profitable.
MENGRAN HE: Thanks, Harish,
for amazing presentation.
So from an analyst's
perspective,
it's really critical
and also helpful
for us to get a
better efficiency
by using Google Cloud
Platform and BigQuery as well
as Looker dashboard, just
like the three examples.
We can definitely reduce
the turnaround time
for generating a forecast
model for our stakeholders.
And we can get a higher and
improve the email targeting
efficiency.
And we also get a better
click-to-conversion ratio
in a very cost-effective way.
And I hope you enjoyed
this webinar session
as much as we did.
And stay tuned for the live
Q&A. And we will be back
in less than a minute.
Welcome back.
So let's get started
with some live questions.
So the first one--
"Have you used cloud dataflow
for the Pipeline as well?
Also, are you doing this on
a real-time basis or batch
process?"
HARISH GAGGAR: Great question.
We have not used--
we have done the
POCs on the dataflow.
But, yeah, this is nothing
we have put into production.
Mostly, we are using the
dataproc in TensorFlow
for our pipeline.
And we are also doing
lot of in-house testing
on the real-time model building.
But currently, most of them
are on the batch processing.
MENGRAN HE: "Do
you have anything
to optimize the
performance of BigQuery?"
HARISH GAGGAR: Yeah.
It depends what kind of
query you're running for.
If you are using the
Legacy SQL query,
we definitely encourage you to
use the [INAUDIBLE] SQL query
and make sure that you keep
all your joins in mind.
And also, it depends
on at what time
you are running those queries.
If you are having
a limited license
and you have many analytics
teams using the BigQuery
at the same time,
I would recommend
that you use those heavy queries
in the batch job in the night.
MENGRAN HE: Next question.
"How does Looker
connect to BigQuery?"
HARISH GAGGAR: So in Looker, we
can first define the connection
to the BigQuery.
On their admin, we
have full control
of connecting to
[INAUDIBLE] database.
And then, we have
LookML feature,
where you just need to
import the BigQuery table.
And it automatically
[? builds ?]
the LookML for you.
All you need to do is
just simply refresh
that model and simply drag
and drop and start visualizing
your data on the BigQuery live.
MENGRAN HE: Next question.
"What advice would you
give to someone who
is starting this process now?"
HARISH GAGGAR: That comes
with a lot of things.
For example, it depends on
what kind of infrastructure
you have, what kind of
instances you want to run.
If you want to run on a
smaller data set, it's fine.
You can spin up the
small GCP instance,
and then you can create
your small project,
and then you can start
with a limited license,
and you can continue
to go from there.
But again, if it is coming
through the mid- and
large-scale business,
you have to decide again
on the architecture side
how many instances you need,
how many projects you need.
Because you ultimately don't
want to one project to create,
and everyone wants your company
to use the same project because
of limited concurrent
query limit.
So you have to split those
projects out and decide
your organization numbers--
how many people who are
going to run the queries,
and what kind of queries
they want to run.
If you organize it
very well, then yeah,
of course, this is a perfect use
case where you can continuously
use and continuously scale
your instance over the cloud
and keep running your queries.
MENGRAN HE: And the next
one-- so, "How up-to-date
is the data that can be
shown on a Looker dashboard?"
HARISH GAGGAR: So that
is also depend on how
you want to refresh the data.
If you want to
refresh on a schedule,
basically, in the
Looker, you can always--
there is an option where you can
create your data SQL queries.
And you can set a trigger
alert for automatically clear
the cache.
So in that way, if someone
go to the Looker dashboard,
it will hit to that
LookerML behind the scenes.
It runs that query and
automatically clears
the cache for you and
show you up-to-date data.
But sometimes, people
don't want to create
[INAUDIBLE] SQL
queries because this
comes with a lot of
performance impact, too.
So they can always go to
their Looker dashboard.
There is option there, and
you can go ahead and click
on that Clear Cache button.
And that will just simply go
and hit to the BigQuery table
and give you up-to-date
data on your dashboard.
MENGRAN HE: Cool.
So next question--
"What made you
decide to switch to BigQuery?"
HARISH GAGGAR: This is what we
something discussed initially,
that it depends from
where you are coming from.
We came from the
columnar database system.
They come with a lot of
the maintenance issues
and also the performance issues.
Because our ETL
queries are very heavy,
and they run terabytes
of data every day,
and it's really slowed down
the performance because
of the complex join.
And ultimately, our
ETL was delaying,
and the analytics team's
not getting the data
on the right time.
And also, it was a lot of
maintenance, also, and also
cost of the infrastructure in
terms of licensing renewal.
So if you consider
all these factors,
Google BigQuery is the place
where you can go to the cloud,
you can spin the
instance so quickly.
It's so easy to go there.
There are a lot of
features rightly available.
You just need to
spin the instance.
You create your project.
And you can always scale
that on demand, basically.
You don't need much interaction
with any support team
or so, because it's
so self-explanatory.
You can simply go ahead
and go to that instance,
and decide your own concurrent
limit, define your own cluster,
and start using the database.
MENGRAN HE: Cool.
I think that's all
the question we got.
So thanks for joining
us this webinar session.
Please stay tuned for
the next session--
"Google Cloud Internet of
Things, From Devices to Cloud,
Enabling Business
Outcomes in a Secure Way."
Thank you.
HARISH GAGGAR: Thank you.